foreign
[Music]
are we the Suns yeah oh never mind
go around go and I see what you're
saying go around
all right can I talk to this guy Whoa
man what a drama queen here buddy
go you can have him get stuff yeah I
know spiders honestly spiders spiders
spiders spiders Wade step away from my
cabin we are a team I will defend my
property knock knock can I come in no
wait why are you laughing
what is this supposed to be I can throw
logs like their paper dude
[Applause]
guys guys guys guys guys guys guys guys
guys guys guys guys he has yeah no the
legs right that's the thing right no her
arms too she has an extra left how many
of her is there whoa I know right I know
right now we can all sleep wonder what
that hit my shelter it would have been
War it would have been War wait I don't
even know that oh you know you're like
on the GPS right yeah well good luck
finding me
[Music]
oh no no hey Bob don't don't
what's wrong Mark I don't know I don't
know come back no I'm so weak I'm so
hungry on Thursday
oh
I don't want that you guys having a good
time in there yeah go for it sound like
we're having a good time
I don't think so look I oh meat I want
to leave and I'm never coming back uh
have fun in there Bob that place not for
me not for me
I'm just gonna leave a Yelp rating
one
wow Kelvin is just non-stop still
getting logged I may have told him to
get some more logs that guy is a trooper
here
that man gets logs like it's his only
thing reason to exist okay listen Camp
version one is great uh sure I think it
might need some modifications okay let's
turn food and water no shut up that's
not important right now oh okay the I
think the central structure is served
better as a parapet
and then a house so I think that should
be the main uh parapet and then we how
do you pick those up
[__] before we end this no why
come here thank you Bingo anyway do you
know remember parapet
parapet
clean up the poop and feed it no no not
a ballet thing no parapet I like a
turret a turret
two turtles oh no see it's our Central
structure with which we can have a high
vantage point and then
yeah sorry no listen that was an
accident I was curious and I let the
intrusive I'm gonna put this away so I
can shut up
in a [__] heart with a spear and he
just moans you all right bud
hey Mark
[Laughter]
[Music]
I need decisions
I'm being attacked
look I put it away I'm not gonna do it
anymore we're like five minutes ago he
won the war he already won the war I did
win oh he had me oh okay am I not
involved that's nice I mean if you want
to be involved I guess but oh yeah
anyway uh I'm gonna go into the woods
and be alone oh good can I help come
with you no Bob we're going to the woods
and be alone oh I'll come in a minute
don't worry guys all right we'll see you
there oh hey Mark what are you doing
here I came here to be alone uh
don't worry about it hey Mark you all
right yeah I'm good don't worry about it
you needed something no no no no
go away oh look he's painting in the
dirt no no no no no no no
you mean oh Mark Mark she's here
shut up shut binders
how do I put away my weapon how do I put
away my weapon how do I put away my what
geez that's it go away weapon there it
is that's it I have yet to see a [__]
spider I am seeing so many spiders guys
she's got three legs that doesn't make
any sense I know oh she runs away
you could probably catch her I think she
I don't want to chase her that's weird
oh Chaser come on Chaser why would this
shut up that's awful oh bloobs hey guys
I got blooms yeah there's blooms around
that's probably hungry and or thirsty
whoa Lake nope that's rocks
uh well I think this might be a fresh
water source so going for it berries do
you have to eat before you're full
it's uh
come on
how do I put away my GPS oh I saw my
lighter out too yo how do I put away my
GPS mushrooms have got to be good for
you oh oh God how do I put away my GPS
it am probably that's it hey mushrooms
not so good
well depends on the mushroom right
whoa yeah it wasn't hallucinogenic
therefore it wasn't good well I was
trying to spear a fish instead I built
the stick totem all right get ready
watch this spearable oh oh I'm so close
you got it Wade figure it out I believe
in you sister did you make a fire Calvin
oh you did look at what a bro look at
this guy
oh I think I just started a forest fire
it's probably fine
what are you okay
Kelvin is just sitting here by the oh
it's going out probably
put it out
turns out you don't need to throw the
stick
oh you just stab him oh man they are
wriggling
leaping around being generally on fire
well that sounds like a Wade problem my
fish vanished Into The Ether I just took
my three cooked fish off maybe it was
full wait you mean I put three fish on
there what do you mean you no I had just
put three fish on and was waiting for
them to cook no you took my three I had
three fish three fish and I put them on
there caught three fish there's no fish
on here on my fish then did you eat all
my fish I didn't eat them I have three
fish in my inventory which is the number
I caught and cooked I myself I have zero
fish which is hilarious because I got
three now I have four and I will watch
you carefully
hey guys I'm starting to think I'm not
good at this wait how do I cook fish
what my fish just
left click it and put it on the thing
where my fish are gone oh if I had
oysters to eat this whole time my fish
are gone my fish are gone wow
unbelievable it's not my fault where did
my fish go couldn't tell you bud but but
they just vanished
where are you guys getting the Rope to
make a spear what do you mean rope
I use tape Galvin
yeah Calvin
oh I see you're having a good time but
can you can you get uh logs no and oh
you can get food stuff guys I'm stupid I
was trying to put a stone on there
instead of using my knife to carve the
stick wait how does it how do I
oh I collect them off the spear first
yes are you do you just have fish on a
spear running around like a big idiot
right now why would I do that I can't
imagine you took my day
sir you stole my fish
I love that when you throw the fish on
it's just a dive bomb Oh Into the Fire
so perfect thank God I love you my
friends
hey how do I get my spear out from under
the wall okay I think I got it never
mind man he is just five steps behind us
the whole time Bob I'm having a hard
time but this is a good spot guys I
found a fish this is a good spot guys
like I really appreciate goodness Wade
you're so smart yeah good job Wade now
all right oh he's working it oh God oh
my God oh God
it turns out that was not the button to
remove fish from spear yeah why is this
fish still wriggling it is extremely
cooked
why why was it that I couldn't tell you
man
it's it wriggles why do I bite the head
first
how do you pick the fish off the spear
without just eating it
just tap e don't hold e which is a
mechanic from the other game we played I
didn't do much in the other game well we
know you definitely ate sometimes so I
don't know what to tell you hey look
guys I gave it we got benches
oh my God
wait I don't think that's what you're
supposed to do this lady's got three
arms
all the adventures now she's elegant
like a ballet dancer or something I
don't know what's going on
hey lady you wanna you wanna fish maybe
I could feed you I'll bite it off in
front of your face I guess whatever
what color is the fish turn when it's
cooked
good color hey lady would you like a
fish it looks very cooked yes lady
excellent ma'am
don't mind these Bohemians yeah
um
the fire seems have gone outweighed
where'd she goes bad for my fish
don't worry I'll put some leaves on it
thanks man look it's cooked lady gone oh
she's right here bud she's by the fire
what oh wait
have fish oh
Kevin Calvary security spear a fish
[Applause]
make peace offering oh wait oops oh lost
fish hold on
hold on I ate it man I got poo fish now
no two fish intimidating best not all
right
um well Wade stares at the fire
menacingly I'm gonna uh I need to go to
the bathroom in real life so I'll keep
me alive I'll be back all right we'll be
right back too actually because I gotta
take a picture of a light bulb okay cool
that sounds really real I can't hear you
okay
okay man
would you like fish
ma'am
ma'am fish for you ma'am
fish
who's giggling maniacally over here
no one I think
no someone just did like from behind Bob
I don't think that's true and I will not
take this slander against Bob's good
name it wasn't what is that oh what is
what oh what is this
yeah yeah yeah
I hear ya look we gotta protect Bob
spiders
whoa spiders
huh oh it's okay the guy's going for you
what's no he's not oh he's running away
it's just like the lady what's the
problem with these you were so
enraptured about the lady dude listen
I'm beginning to think you're a bit over
judgmental
duh that has nothing to do with this
yeah well we have nothing to do with
each other so
what do you mean we're at War you mean
no peace
huh is it Aaron war was that the line I
don't know what you're talking about
you know in space with wug I don't know
what you're talking about
uh anyway a YouTube production oh man
we're all just chilling
you know the prequel to iron lung I'm
facing the wrong way oh you got company
coming you want to feed him yeah
Kelvin
you not cook while you sit oh Calvin
notices the the people
could you go get more logs and drop them
here all right I think we should build
our camp here because it's got a nice
good vantage point it feels naturally
defensible from this Alcove and it's got
a fresh water supply and access to uh
the rest of the island
it's got natural barriers over there and
I agree yeah it's great we just need to
clear oh maybe that'd actually be better
for Kelvin to do clear the area
whoa whoa ow ow Kelvin God damn it
Calvin I love you Kelvin oh so now you
believe that it was him that was clearly
Kelvin but it wasn't when Bob saw Kelvin
do it no not at all because I don't
trust your judgment I trust my own eyes
all right so we need logs
yeah that's why I have him Gathering
logs yes
excellent perfect
this is glorious oh my head itches can
you scratch it me no actually and I
don't know if I would even if I was
there I'm really not feeling the
teamwork here like I I I feel like
there's no need for me to scratch your
head because it detracts from what I'm
doing and part of the saying you scratch
my head I'll scratch yours that's not
the saying something about backs I'm
pretty sure it's like the Beast with two
back scratches backs to back
I'm like that also what can you build
the stones
I just stacked the stone and it's man
once again you're a step behind I was
stacking Stones before you even got to
the stone stacking parts of that
man now one day you'll catch up
Bronze Age that joke doesn't really land
yeah well they rarely knew with you I
understand that but hey we can't all be
Geniuses hey oh man
listen will you stick around me enough
you're gonna learn a thing or two but
before you do that you gotta learn a few
lessons you know namely I'm in charge
I'm the best and I'm both uh incredible
and amazing and if you listen to me
maybe you'll survive
oh God don't look over there
oh
hmm
you mistake me for the the person over
there I was trying to throw it over your
head to hit that person why would you do
that this is how you throw oh you got oh
my God
you're angry
they're very angry
I got one
nice work thanks
thank you
all right did you tell Kelvin to stop or
something because he's not Gathering
logs there's a lot more of these guys
you're still doing this
um yeah he's just uh he's pointing out
the fact that there are people here and
we should probably take care of them
before they get too high in numbers it's
okay they're only surrounding us
I feel like this is what we should do oh
yeah they attacked me first
uh so just take him out and um
that's it
that doesn't sound good
whatever that was it did not
um I think what we're gonna need is uh
to
um start really uh building up defenses
um I got a funny feeling that uh because
we haven't been doing that we're gonna
be very behind in terms of the things
that
all right uh here's how we're I I think
we should do it I'll I'll start devising
up the Outer Perimeter and then you work
on some defenses for the the beach side
the sand side I'll work on the uh the
forest side defenses and then you work
on the beach side are you saying the
side I'm currently building the stone
wall on or not that where are you
building a snowman
why why are there why there what is that
going to defend
what a second what is that gonna do for
us I figured we'd go all the way around
you know have a full Roundy Roundy
and do what how many stores do you think
you can get there aren't enough stones
well not with that attitude well with
any attitude I I highly doubt that
you're going to be able to get enough
stones for that
look how high it's already gotten it's I
don't think that's true that's where
thinking gets you sometimes you just
gotta do
well I'm doing over here so you do over
there and that'll be all that you do and
then I'll do all that I do oh hey I got
bones now why do you have bones
oh
hello
we okay we are under attack they are
mean and they are angry Mars attacked
one of them no it attacked me it
attacked me
wow
don't worry Mark I'll help you murder
this person no questions thank you I
appreciate it
that's why we're friends I know what it
takes
for very different reasons
I'll take it anyway we're building up a
defensive wall okay it kind of seems
like the wall is in very disparate
locations I gotta be yeah well okay Wade
was building I don't know why he was
building a stone wall over there I am
going to die
isn't this where you want to build the
house over here in the sand I'm trying
to build an Outer Perimeter the
delineation of the perimeter what are
you doing building this over here
we need to barricade the Wall come here
bud we have natural fortifications with
these rocks here how to connect them
come here all right there we go that's a
good spot there bud I want these rocks
that they jump on top of an attack yeah
we can jump them to whoa
oh hey Mark I found some breathers yeah
breathers is that what they're calling
call the living
all right well am I a breather then yeah
I guess technically
interesting you're part of the party so
you're you're I wouldn't call you a
breather okay I don't like the way they
climb things and whatnot
gotta be honest yeah I don't like it
either but you know nothing we can do
about it it's not my favorite I like how
I I haven't attacked these guys so we're
chill I appreciate that
all right cool I mean I'm chill with him
I don't know all right Mark one thing we
didn't think about when we agreed to
build the stone wall is how we might run
out of stone
interesting man I wish I had thought
about that way in advance once again
your mental abilities proved Superior
you know I yield my time all right
winner of this week's episode
huh wow why are there so many oh this
has been an episode of distractible the
whole time oh wow really
well it's a new day new crimes uh if you
haven't already go follow Bob at Bob
skirm Mark and Mark skirm and me at
weight scream that's not my
that's what your channel name will be
when you get uh your AdSense canceled
again I want to know okay no need to
bring that up but I want to know if
there's anyone out there that actually
doesn't know that we actually have a
podcast 100 how after all this time of
us talking about did people not realize
have people like thought it's actually
just a joke and no one can tell like our
bits from reality yes like we actually
do have a podcast no one cares video
exclusive on Spotify do you think anyone
cares about that so there's also the
group that's like they talk about it
therefore I won't watch it because
they're really edgy
some people that do know but they're
like it must not I mean I like all of
their content but I won't like that
because they mentioned it oh yeah yeah
oh man they're laughing oh this guy's
giggling
before I even saw them they're terrified
hi Mark on top of the giggly one there
he is
I'm getting them all right
don't worry
I'm getting them good job yep got him
wow my wall is looking amazing we might
need one of your little uh not hammocks
hi ladies
hi I'm gonna call you Legasus what are
you doing here oh oh she's dancing at
you oh oh that's strange so is she
supposed to have three appendages I
think so yeah uh oh there's a hole
there's a wall there
ma'am
ma'am ma'am
oh she's dancing oh it's okay it's fine
okay okay there you go
all right this is letter B dude she
leaps she does leap we got three legs
she's straight up leaps yeah hey Calvin
hey Kelvin you build a shelter uh follow
me Kelvin
no wait but he was logging yeah well you
know we need the logs for the wall tired
he's tired he's resting what do I give a
[__] kelvin's not even human as far as
I'm concerned what do you mean he's
totally human he's just our little our
little minion man he does whatever we
want hey Mark you know where the wall is
uh no actually there might be a guy
coming from the side where the wall
isn't ah that's interesting so that I
don't believe you unforeseen situation
maybe but Mark's really not a Believer
unless he sees it I've learned that
about him yeah
where's like the do we have a uh do we
whoa do we whoa
tarp yeah how do we make a shelter did
you tell what's his face to make it no
he's not listening he's not he's tired
or something I don't know
tell him to quit being such a baby
make us a God dang no not a f oh he's
gonna make a fire I didn't oh no guys oh
no
we really need a shelter it's really
dark guys
that's great please don't a lot of bones
in our fire at least yes do make a
shelter yeah tell them to make a shelter
it's dark uh is there a water collection
thing or am I out of my mind right now
no no there used to be with the turtle
shells it doesn't say to build shelter
it's not even an option maybe he doesn't
have any tarp maybe we're out of tarp
maybe we're out of tarp
someone's got to go get the tarp just
have them get have them get logs and
let's build a log cabin but it's too
dark
let's build a let's build a hunting
shelter yeah build a hunting shelter how
do I
you eat there we go
yeah protection oh but I was about to do
that I did it well all right fine then
without this is gonna take logs I can't
even see how do I wait oh do you have to
do the logs first is that the deal I
don't know oh this [__] thing where's
Kelvin he's resting
Kev Kevin my boy why is it so dark at
night I'm turning up the brightness oh
that's barely better
don't Harvest from my wall I'm not I'm
not I don't care
you don't you dare don't what stop it
don't
you don't have to I just got too long
you dare it's fine
we need two logs we got two locks good
well you guys must have gone out and
yeah I went and got those logs all on my
own self
from with another place where there was
logs oh I'm saving sleep all right sleep
sleep
flip sleep don't worry I'll sleep in a
minute sleep oh yeah yeah
I'll be sleeping I'm gonna sleep in a
minute oh okay sleep sleep
what the hell oh why belong we can't
sleep it doesn't seem very
light sleep sleep again sleep sleep
again sleep again yeah
ah there we go okay no sleep for us what
is that why is that happening ah maybe
two enemies too near I'm sleeping I'm
sleeping correctly and properly also huh
no no no no no sleep
oh
yeah there are times a charm you're so
smart I had a gut feeling man you knew
what was up
sometimes you just know it when you know
when you knows it
that's what I'm saying yeah that's what
I'm saying uh all right that's what I'm
talking about that's what I'm talking
about all right Kelvin you go get some
logs can you get some rocks why
because these things are a lot better
than logs probably
nope you're not even I'm gonna go drink
some water and get some fish yeah oh hey
bud you uh not exist
man good thing these guys don't mutate
horribly into giant monstrosities yeah
thank God thank God
there's one thing that we know it's how
safe we are right now we are so safe I
don't feel very safe well you don't know
anything that's going on how do we make
a gate
hip rope stick stick
[Music]
I'm not answering you I'm talking to my
own self
ape rope stick stick okay props rope
stick
guys I made a boo
made him go you made a boo boo I made a
boo
man they really can just cross the river
can't they I thought the wrap would be
like a defensible but all of a sudden
they are not even perturbed about the
river situation tell you what bird Glory
oh [__]
wait guys see you later remember that
thing about the firewood
yeah but the fish was burning so I was
gonna get the fish off and unfortunately
our shelter is located in position
[Music]
hey Mark if you build on the wall you
can get the achievement Tradesman what
it's building a structure with it that
uses over 50 logs oh man oh hey can you
move the raw fish and put them back on
for some reason they
all right try to take the cooked fish
but I guess my inventory is close to
myself how about you make your own
fustry hits the wall is it gonna cause
Brum oh wouldn't you like to know
[Laughter]
well thankfully I missed so uh we're all
good forever well now I'm so curious we
might have to just give that a try well
no we don't have to though I will we
pretty much have to no we don't have to
though
Calvin are you getting logs or what my
dude that got that that that creature
dude
jumped over me placing the log as if he
was going under the door that was
closing in a movie cliche
ow hey a thing attacked me but jumped
into the fire so now it's on fire yeah
he's he's rolling you dummy he's fine
man these guys aren't smart not like us
we're very smart smart like us men yeah
what what ah
wow I don't know how high we need to
make it but probably three rocks High
seems good enough to me I don't know
you guys still on this the the the rock
wall
it's on the hard the hard close
perimeter Mark we're doing we're doing
the Lord
uh how did the wall fare no the Wall's
fine turns out if you kind of orbit
around the tree as it's falling down
yeah it goes on yeah oh that's weird
a little strange must be a bug
I thought that era of Wade was over
well no then some logs fell where I was
looking for rocks so oh I'm so sorry
that must have been so difficult for you
it felt so sarcastic Mark that's pretty
rude I would never be rude
oh god oh
I mean I what are you talking about what
do you mean oh God no I'm
I hope that's the sound of logs being
gathered
it was the sound of rocks
oh okay you know you're right so now I'm
just saying what you're saying you mean
what you say
look out Kevin
no wait no oh it's good it's good it's
good it's twisting it's twisting it's
fine
it sounds fine it sounds so fine right
now
some Screaming going on down there
they're just like oh sorry Calvin oh God
I hit Kelvin oh no
you're a monster what are you doing I'm
trying that poor man
just trying to bring you logs for your
idiotic perimeter wall oh I'm sorry look
when the walls get breached and we're
being overrun you're really gonna want
to be on the right side of my wall and
the right side of History so why don't
you come crying to me when you're
trapped hey white flowers are okay to
eat
why don't you eat a flower
okay I didn't even deserve anything
I never want to hear you
okay
you all right Mark make it a win
make him hurt he's already laughing
really silly I don't know what else
I don't know how to add to that
yeah yeah you're right
you guys know any logs we left down
there
yeah no I don't know it doesn't have the
same how do we get weighed Mark help me
develop something oh wait What's your
deal
what's my biggest insecurity yeah
security uh probably our friendship
what
air quotes around that or yeah like
you're insecure about our friendship
that that we're friends I'm just gonna
let you figure out what you wanted I
gotta be honest I gotta feels that feels
too mean uh I don't want to go after
that one okay all right perimeter wall
is almost complete I found a boot
and it still has the foot
uh
uh good
spark Calvin made you a big pile of logs
you're not even using I just wanted you
to know that yeah well I'm trying to
make it so that the next phase of it is
easier to get underway because there's a
ready supply logs I'm trying to help him
help me you know what Calvin cow Calvin
hey now can we call you cow cow okay
oh my God guys then the wall is complete
dude I can't get back uh so impellative
oh oh oh
uh Mark I'm gonna go around here it
really hurts
can we take a nap or something how do we
get out of this situation
what do you mean
cow cow
why does this guy sound like it was
recorded in somebody's untreated bedroom
Cal if cow die
did we lose Cal I don't see him on the
map where's Cal what do you mean is he
down
oh no he's just way the hell far away
for some reason Cal come here I think he
was scared cow
cow
oh no he doesn't do river crossing so
good that's the problem with Calvin no
oh boy well that's just awkward that's
what that is all right well we need to
figure out how to build a door or
something
it's Calvin
Kelvin hey Mark I don't know how to
build a door I lied uh we need like a
Gatehouse thing going on I think
that sounds right get how do we break
this rock it's in my way get rocks and
drop them here Calvin rocks but we're
not even going wrong
no we need blocks coming out of our Bing
bongs really that hard to get the
answers no but we need to the river is
not defensible we we discovered this so
we need to figure out a way to make the
river more defensible
stone wall sure sure what am I
connecting this wall to the log thing
I'm trying oh man I feel these we just
on two different pages because we're
just like
I feel like we we could have claimed so
much more landscape if we had not built
the wall so close to our
you know or anything
uh easy to say nay when you're a
naysayer that's what I always put one
Spike on the log wall
that was an accident I gotta be honest
that was not you can't
oh God go go